I'm gonna ask you something I want you
to be honest where did you pee in this
house because I can smell it so tell me
where you peed
[Music]
Jack get down get down
I didn't know you had a guest-starring
role on Parks and Recreation
I don't know dick I think I should pay
these bills lord knows you won't do it
do you like that food I guess you like
it I know let's make your poop stink
[Music]
try to keep the litter in the box when
you go to the bathroom that's all we
have a litter box
I thought not yet you're not there yet
look look at what I'm pointing to keep
the litter in the box cuz you don't
sweep I sweep good tighten we give you
the room yeah good boy that's right
you're a warrior you guys are coming
here and kill your mom but you're gonna
kill him what'd you do today huh you're
the best
you're a tiger no one can beat you you
play that's cool because I worked how
did you contribute to this household put
your ass in my face that towel
time to bring out the big boy you ready
for this yeah that's the stuff
the dead little cat come down the
hallway and try to talk to me again huh
the neighbor's cat stop being a player
I'm sorry good it's just funny you're
never gonna catch it get a room
check this out jack cooking Jack I
better not be the coatrack what are you
looking at
do you love me are you going
[Music]
here so your grandmother wants me to
come home but before Christmas I don't
really have the funds to do that which
she does not understand I'm a crazy cat
lady no I don't think so
[Music]